even before the historic meeting pope
francis said he would make no attempt to
mediate in the middle east peace process
his invitation was simply a call to pray
together
the unusual gathering took place in
unusual surroundings
jewish muslim and christian spiritual
leaders gathered in the garden of the
vatican
but the most significant guests were
israeli president shimon peres
instead of political speeches there was
music
prayers were read by religious leaders
from all three main religions
pope francis has said in the past that
he believes in the power of prayer to
change everything
including the situation in the middle
east
the pope's invitation to religious
leaders to join him in prayer at the
vatican
came as a surprise during his visit to
the region two weeks ago
that trip was full of symbolism francis
prayed at the western wall in jerusalem
and at the israeli-built barrier between
the jewish state and the palestinian
territories
many believers here in rome say they
hope the pope's concerned to heal the
wounds on both sides
and his belief in reconciliation despite
the problems of the past
will give a boost to the stalled peace
process
there is so much hate but i believe
francis can find a new approach
francis is not the first pope to get
involved in the mideast conflict
but his simple humble style might help
him gain success
pope francis is due to hold talks with
both the israeli and palestinian leaders
after the joint prayer session